READY IN NOVEMBER. ZONE,
WRAPS IT UP AND THE AVSY LINDHOT
INVOLVED IN THAT.
HERE'S
SCORES!
[ HORN ]
>> NAZEM KADRI LETS IT FLY AS HE
GOT TO THE TOP OFTO GET JUICE IS
BUILDING.
THEY'VE DONE ALL OF AWAY BY
RISTOLAINEN. RICE.
THE BIG I SEE IT -- MAKAR WITH E
WRIST SHOT AND GOALS BY DEFENSEN
IN THEORN ]
>> TERRIFIC JOB BY J.T. COMPHER.
HE STAYS WITH IT.
HE'S ABLE TO BASH I PICK UP, HIS
THIRD POINT OF
[ HORN ]
>> IT WAS DEFLECTED.
THE AVS HAVE TAKEN A TO -- IT SO
HIT BOTH OF TO SEEK TAKE IT TAKT
AWAY.
THE
[LAUGHTER]
>> COGLIANO FINDS MacDERMID
LONG SHOT -- SKOSH!
[ HORNWORKS HARDER THAN UP BY Z.
PERIOD.
>> I THINK IF YOU WERE JARED
BEDNAR, YOU WOULD SAY, THE GAME
HAS BEEN A LITTLE MORE WH YET TO
SHOT SAVED, FRANCOUZ AND
BACKHAND ANDRABS THE
REBOUND.
SHOOTS AND SCORES RIGHT
OFF THE DRAW!
HE DANCED!
WHO DON'T SCORE A LOT,  IN
THE THIRD.